today's announcement the largest
security assistance package in total
value that we have committed so far
reflects our enduring commitment to
support Ukraine
this package includes the authorization
of presidential drawdown of equipment
from U.S inventories valued at up to
2.85 billion dollars
and it includes an additional
225 million dollars in foreign military
financing to contribute to the long-term
capacity and modernization of Ukraine's
military
so let me highlight some of the
capabilities included in this package
first as President Biden announced
yesterday we are committing 50 Bradley
infantry fighting vehicles with 500 tow
anti-tank missiles and 250
000 rounds of 25 millimeter ammunition
the Bradley Vehicles will further
enhance Ukraine's ability to conduct
complex Maneuvers in almost all weather
conditions and terrain especially in the
South and the east of the country
the Bradley is a tracked armored vehicle
that is agile provides mounted Firepower
and is a significant anti-armor
capability
this complements a series of armor
commitments by the United States and our
allies these include a French commitment
of AMX 10 light tanks a German
commitment of martyr infantry fighting
Vehicles both announced this week as
well as a recent joint U.S Netherlands
commitment to provide upgraded t-72
tanks
this package also includes a hundred
m113 armored personnel carriers
55 mine resistant ambush protected
vehicles or mraps and another 138
Humvees
these additional m113s beyond the 200 we
have already committed will further
enhance Ukraine's Fleet of tracked
armored vehicles to support operations
in the east and south
we have now committed more than 1 300
Humvees to enable Ukraine to protect and
transport their forces during maneuver
operations in the case of the Bradley
what you are seeing is a recognition
that this is the right time for us to
provide this armored capability this is
the right time for Ukraine to take
advantage of its capabilities to change
the dynamic on the battlefield and from
a maintenance and sustainment standpoint
and this is really important the
ukrainians have demonstrated a lot of
growing Proficiency in maintenance and
sustainment both within Ukraine and
relying on new systems that we have set
up with our allies and partners to
provide what we call tele maintenance in
many instances so at this point the
ukrainians really are set up for Success
once we are able to train them on the
system and I think it's important to
note that this also comes at the
auspicious time that we are expanding
our training program many of you have
heard about our launch that will happen
later this month of new combined arms
training so we will be able to enable
the ukrainians to take advantage of this
capability and again not just actually
to employ it on the battlefield but to
maintain and sustain it when you and in
terms of your question about the timing
it'll take a couple of months basically
to get this capability fielded to get
the ukrainians trained that that new
training program that we're starting it
it's roughly a battalion's worth of
forces at a time so roughly 500 soldiers
over the course of roughly a month and
we're adding on the Bradley training but
the the tank capability that you that
you reference this is something that we
absolutely agree that Ukraine does need
tanks it's one of the reasons that we
partnered with the Netherlands to
refurbish a number of t-72 tanks that
are already arriving on the battlefield
but we have to be cognizant of
Maintenance and sustainment
considerations with tanks and certainly
we know that the Abrams tank in addition
to being a gas guzzler is quite quite
challenging to maintain so we want to
look across the board at the range of
tank capabilities and and see where we
can all support Ukraine but again we're
already doing that with the the t-72
tanks and now we see France also with
their light tanks okay so again when I
talk about um you know changing that
Dynamic on the battlefield and enabling
the Ukrainian Armed Forces with
additional capability it is so that they
can not just um you know apply artillery
to a given position but can also
integrate with maneuver and actually be
able to regain territory and the Bradley
specifically has formidable anti-armor
capabilities that will work against you
know every every kind of armored
capability that Russia has fielded in
Ukraine but the but the ukrainians need
more than that and that's why you know
you see us surging other types of
Mobility capabilities not just the
United States again but also allies in
addition the package includes
significant artillery commitments these
include 18 self-profo propelled 155
millimeter howitzers known as the
Paladin system and an an additional 155
millimeter I'm sorry and additional 155
millimeter artillery rounds
this is the first commitment of U.S
commitment of the self-propelled
howitzers which will provide greater
protection and maneuverability than the
toad howitzers previously provided and
will complement self-propelled howitzers
already provided by allies
we are also providing an additional 36
105 millimeter toad howitzers to
strengthen Ukraine's layered approach to
fires as well as 105 millimeter rounds
these capabilities will complement and
work with the expanded U.S led training
beginning this month that will build
Ukraine's capacity to conduct joint
maneuver and combined operations we will
ensure Ukraine has both the equipment
and the skilled forces necessary to
sustain its efforts to push back on
Russian aggression
we are also committing 4 000 Zuni
aircraft Rockets which can be mounted on
Ukraine's existing aircraft to engage
air or ground Targets in the category of
air defense which is still a top
priority for Ukraine given Russia's
ongoing missile attacks we are
committing Rim 7 missiles these can be
integrated into Ukraine's soviet-era
tactical surface-to-air missile systems
and this provides the ukrainians with
additional capabilities to defend
against Russian aerial attacks we will
continue to support Ukraine's urgent
requirement for Air Defense capabilities
to defend against Russia's brutal
attacks which as you noticed continued
throughout the holiday season